hello and welcome to the CEO playing
outcome from Israel okay another game
with this experimental line experimental
for me yeah it's a well-known of course
but surprised that he went Bishop detune
and not you can go with this a three
before business and fianchetto and
steady went to d2 not quite sure why
okay so he wants to go 95 i guesses I
already have for this trick a couple of
times I wonder if now be 52 still 95 hmm
Bishop a 395 take stakes and this is
kind of sensitive c7 hmm d 5 is also
unclear d5 what stairs maybe is going to
be 5 after that what could could be a
point
ok covering this and somehow now is set
up make some sense ok ok i just take
this now and see how bad this is it
wasn't my plan but anyway
Jim I mean it cannot be so bad for me
but I'm also not not a fan of my
position okay so it knows me there so
I'm happy that he at least I get
something yeah did something kind of
controversial give him some they gives
himself some porn weaknesses him
jammu p1 looks normal CF anything else
don't quite see it 95 there's really
five that's not working this one okay
okay as a queen is attacking give fire
but i can take plane 93 right anyway
let's do this 93 years groups eh stuff
can also take this first and then go
with the night taking d4 and try to take
the bishop his king is slightly slightly
weak cell
it's so easy for what ok so I'm going to
keep it simple check
stairway to to do this if he well if you
move the King bag I have Queen h3 so
maybe yes to kill king of one Queen
entry looks pretty bad on Kings you want
it doesn't even have a check so probably
has to move the king and then I grab age
too okay so what is your move now okay
clean f3 maybe this is the this is the
idea okay um what if I go clean to f5
first Queen f5 the threaten screen f2 so
look f1 tweenage three Rugare to locally
one is made this should be the end of it
right Queen f5 yes no other move to
cover queen of two right it's not that's
not in blunder this now would be kind of
annoying ready but I think I think it
does work it's a bit more precise now
queen ii a three queen h2 is made rucca
f2 rookie one is also made so and
there's a pawn on d5 not allowing Queen
f7 for things like that
white resigns hmm there was a son enter
to the game I was a bit surprised that
he played that quick divorce stuff oh he
had 95 in this position higher I was
luckier I didn't see that one didn't
didn't didn't see the idea now I'm under
pressure here on f7 yeah this is what he
should do instead he went to form and
this is this is leading to trouble I
could have taken only three already
which I didn't do well yeah I'm better
but not winning and did this was losing
is Jack yeah King f1 this is what he has
to try okay it also loses so this is
Madame yeah this is made made an X ok
yeah he pretty much killed himself there
with the untimely opening of the
position but he had 95 that was a was a
was a good shot I just wonder about the
opening that really looks very ok who
black but still I am this is interesting
I wanted to play Bishop everywhere
there's always this 95 idea which is
very annoying I don't want to allow him
that doubles my pawns and this is simply
simply not not good right I mean here he
will take him gaps were played this this
is what the engine is recommending yeah
it makes an awful lot of sense this is
an idea NC 696 let that fits very well
yeah there's a reason why those bloody
engines have such high ratings food okay
thanks for watching